oh uh-uh tile Brock what the hell y'all
two doing here we're keeping your
company afloat you're welcome I don't
know if estrogen makes you forgetful but
we're your top two salesmen uh you're
not my two top salesmen check the
board okay so we missed a day and we
fell down a Slaughter to big deal big
deal y'all ain't been here in two weeks
week we cuz we got that wig that's it
that's where the time went yeah y'all up
so guess what because y'all haven't been
making me no money y'all are dead to me
you haven't been selling any Wheels any
gears and y'all damn sure ain't been
selling no teeny tiny brushes okay I
know we're not supposed to say this
anymore because it's not acceptable or
whatever but you're being a yeah
and I would say that the way you're
acting right now is actually very
okay well I can show y'all two a